[Music]
in self-rescue News News at 10:00 I
thought your big me out of my own misery
because we're not swimming right you got
to use your arms yeah you have to get
off that's right this marker right here
submitted by David from Ontario I am NOT
Ontario what Ontario oh I was thinking
Airport trucker stop in a outlet mall
okay
Ontario California they're gonna turn
Ontario Airport into an international
area already yes dude it already is
direct flight yeah so if you want to
live out there in the buff up nowhere
now you have an International Airport
now hey maybe we should always think
about Rancho Cucamonga hello what you're
gonna tell them but we're gonna move now
or Ontario Riverside or Montana living
in Montana
property noise probably read a month
pretty nice together like Rancho
Cucamonga
it just sounds funny Cucamonga yeah it
sounds like some [ __ ] the Ninja Turtle
sings oh yes I would love to manga Pizza
kid manga a kidnap thirteen-year-old who
escaped her captor is now getting the
25-thousand dollar reward for saving
herself [ __ ] this twelve-year-old
[ __ ] favor so 13 even better did she
like escaped because I didn't read she
did I was trying to find out more
details of her escape well what I heard
was um so he would have people come over
and [ __ ] and he would put her underneath
his bed and then like barrack seal it
off through a Christmas party with his
family - yeah no they had no idea she
was there I had no idea so what they
said was that she just ended up being
able to kick it after some time and then
that's how she just got out I couldn't
find that turned it on the news it could
have been made up but like on the only
thing I did hear about her escape is
like how she was found can you catch me
up to speed
okay so Jamie
thirteen years old her parents were
murdered
oh no that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] man named
Jake Patterson he's 21 years old that's
the curse P do you mean Jake or Jake up
I've ever met really you should go to
school in Georgia a lot of shitty ass
Jacob there Jake up I've met that I know
that many Jacobs they've all been really
cool this is the first one he was like
biting the evil for the rest of an
employee yeah she took calls Pizza
called evil
apparently the Jake saw the Jamie at a
bus stop and then followed her home and
then he planned how he was gonna kidnap
her and all this stuff and so hand it up
I mean oh we are but they're disgusting
like who looks at a [ __ ] kid and
they're like ooh when I see a kid I'm
like you're [ __ ] smelly dude smell
like asphalt backpacks wet and sticky
hands that's what you are and that's a
tease you're talking all kinds of [ __ ]
thinking they know everything actually
what's Jewish shut the [ __ ] up dude it's
not a word yeah [ __ ] kidnapping
oh that's what happened Rossi I know I
can't wait to attack does that age a
little bit pull my fingers back no can
you do like Korean punishment tactics on
them what is that like just this is what
my dad Kim Chi and the ice so stick your
fist down till the punches don't [ __ ]
face into it run boy
punch your face what are you telling him
to do on you do to your own kids all I'm
gonna do to my kids but I don't have a
kid yet and you need to do it faster kid
that's at that age I keep literally
almost a teenager yeah sweet but you
didn't whip him early enough and he's
[ __ ] sweet of [ __ ] how do you think
you got so sweet yeah but you see this
Dean if I beat his ass I'll beat my ass
yeah yeah man
banana face come on now anyway so then
this dude he goes into the home shoots
the both parents in the head and gets
her and he kept her for 88 days he
murdered the parents that was like the
first thing I said dude yeah he stalked
her oh I thought he just stopped her at
whatever bus stopped and picked her
celebrate it was love at first sight and
then from that point on he was just like
infatuated or what
he would like plotted how to make her
his I mean you could tell he's a
complete loser cuz he's 21 to the school
cuz he also looks just like a 13 year
old girl I know okay this is Davey and
that was like I don't want to be well I
will be rude because he's a [ __ ]
murderer and pedophile but he is like
come on if I were to put up 40 other
people with them I'd be like which one
is gonna do this thing you'd be like
this guy this one time textbook loser
look he looks like you kids
I trust my stereotypical judgment a lot
if I saw this guy walking around I'll be
like this fool probably jacks off to
animal porn that's what comes off my I
mean like something's wrong it's my
natural [ __ ] at the grocery store
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna try to take the moral
higher ground and be like oh I am
accepting of everyone I trust my
instincts and that's why I'm alive
that's what humans have in steam yeah
vibes are like a real thing sometimes
someone walks in the room you're like
athletes kill somebody for sure you
never felt that from somewhat no you
don't go to the Albertson's right here
that's all trying to go to H Mart this
that's criminals really you know who I
don't trust people who smell onions they
smell onions go to a grocery store you
see these [ __ ] they just go up
and they smell an onion and I just want
to come up to his aid hey first of all
that doesn't do [ __ ] like what are you
smelling a [ __ ] onion for you know
they're trying to see what the quality I
could tell that they've never cooked
before going up to like a they're going
up to an onion in there going you
[ __ ] serial killer onions textbook
loser
yeah onion smell oh dude that's a [ __ ]
onion smell but he has the skin of a
nice Korean girl
I did not see one pimple on it look at
that [ __ ] Japanese girl skin dude how
nice move why does he look like a elbow
I was gonna say like a thumb I'm just
saying he hasn't knows it'll smell
onions it's possible I mean smelly no is
he six nine he's even that tall nine
inches long secret okay I don't know cuz
it says it's like two marks of the six
nine and so well how did he kill that
mom that mom was ferocious she left
she'll [ __ ] somebody up and the dad
looks like a white rapper he looks like
Alec Baldwin pretending to be a white
rapper oh my god may she rest in peace
yeah but he looks like Alec Baldwin
trying to be a white rapper I know
oh he was auditioning for eight mile a
little laced in peace yes so the parents
they worked at Hormel food or they
worked at Jenny uh Hormel no jennie-o
turkey store and so the parent company
is Cornell and so they offered a $25,000
reward oh the company the company was
try to find her when she was missing oh
now they said that they're gonna give
her the money
that makes us awesome Hormel I'm buying
your chili again dude that's amazing so
I'm assuming that there was a lot of
rape involved I'm sure oh I hope he's
just like one of those people that just
wants to look at her I hope so too but
they haven't mentioned that but I've
read that's a nightmare you you you get
both of your parents killed you get
[ __ ] by bad thing I think it's like
literally the worst though only 13 do if
I was a 13 year old girl you know my
future like like I'm dreaming of my
future and I love my husband and like
all this stuff and like Who am I fall in
love with and I get this [ __ ] nasty
looking creature oh my god at what age
was she kidnapped 1300 unless you got
free when she was there 88 days later oh
wow okay I thought she was really young
and then she grew stronger so we're not
trying to pay attention to the story at
all that's tomato
Oh baby
I told you all of it he's like so her
brother did that but how did a black
girl turn to a white girl do you
remember that story of that little black
girl like like she kicked and then ran
away you talking about the girl that you
threw the rope yeah yeah yeah I remember
did you guys recently hear who burns how
about later but this guy broke into this
house somewhere in LA so he broke into
the house with intent to burglarize
right so he got all the [ __ ] that he
wanted to get he was leaving it outside
of the house he went back in and noticed
a little girl who's like a teen sleeping
in her bed and he was like all shame
about to get me some of that so he goes
in trying to rape her but he didn't
realize that this little girl yes yes
yes you [ __ ] his [ __ ] eye she
kept him there no he don't way but keep
she kicked his ass [ __ ] yeah break her
arm dude that's so [ __ ] upsetting for
a grown-ass man to try to rape a little
girl and this she's just [ __ ] Wiggly
as [ __ ] he's like three minutes he just
goes I'm done you know if you're just
gonna be that way
martial arts is all in for Tiger but if
I have a daughter that she's mandatory
martial arts is not an option I so many
[ __ ] creeps out there dad I'm just
like man dude are mandatory for tyka to
maybe see a part of me wants to put my
daughter in jiu-jitsu but I don't want
[ __ ] some other dudes touching my
daughter at the same time [ __ ]
rolling with her [ __ ] like put the
[ __ ] [ __ ] hands off my daughter
you sick [ __ ] hey if Nala and Simba can
do it so can your daughter
I think young boys young boys could be a
target of rape too until maybe unless
they're like a seven-foot boy which I
think psycho will be
but you know a under-13 he's still he's
still it's still dangerous is a [ __ ]
giant dude like I haven't seen him maybe
like a month and a half and he's a
[ __ ] giant I love it I will just talk
about 17 for real 17 months we did math
no 17 years he's [ __ ] 70 years old
that was quick I blame the hormones in
milk yeah
put more hormones in coz I like I like
how big he is getting full his puberty
already he's putting up his Adam's
apples [ __ ] huge right now big baby
from spirited away but it's actually a
mouse sport yes you see here who said
the ABCs it's like a frightening bid
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]